[Music]
let's be frank everybody knows about or
at least has heard of call of duty you
know team deathmatch you played zombies
with your friends and when you think
about shooters Call of Duty's one of the
first that comes to mind
it's been described as games console
gold call of duty call of duty call of
duty the new call dating call of duty
call of duty call of duty Call of Duty
game from the original World War 2
trilogy and groundbreaking release of
modern warfare 2 the launch of the
titles of very own massive esports
league and now the fourth iteration of
black ops claude is one of the
best-selling video game franchises of
all time and it's not going away anytime
soon
and
Battle Royale is here it's captured the
minds of some of the world's most
beloved gaming personalities and Call of
Duty has brought its own arsenal of
nostalgia and impeccable gun mechanics
to the hottest shooter format on the
planet this is Call of Duty's Story Call
of Duty began as a first-person shooter
set in World War two and was built off
of quake 3 arena z' engine when it first
released in October 2003 the game was
developed by Infinity Ward and released
by Activision during an era where FPS
games were taking over the mainstream
the first Call of Duty set the bar for
what playing a shooter on console should
feel like it immersed you in three near
to life storylines including american
and british paratroopers and the soviet
red army
[Music]
and as the Call of Duty franchise
evolved it gave us all we needed to
satisfy that craving after several World
War two themed iterations Activision and
infinity war dropped call of duty 4
modern warfare in 2007
[Music]
this was infinity ward's first cod title
after taking a year off in favor of
another developer Treyarch with the
release of cod for these two developers
would start to trade year to year who
had the rights to develop the new cod
game at the time this seemed
insignificant but would become a
defining reason as to why cod titles
differentiate so much between iterations
and why it continues to be made annually
from the beginning the developers at
Infinity Ward wanted to create a modern
shooter while Activision was set on a
world war 2 game this difference of
opinion would be the start of what was a
messy relationship between Activision
and Infinity Ward yes the legal for all
between publishers Activision and
developers Infinity Ward got even hotter
today with allegations emerging that
Activision began to run a police state
like business for those that have been
following the battle since it erupted
back in March this is just another
installment in a legal fight that
quickly turned into the ugliest and
largest developer dispute the gaming
world has ever seen
in 2010 the two heads of Infinity Ward
Jason West and Vince Zampella were fired
due to insubordination
these actions prompted a 36 million
dollar lawsuit followed by the two just
fired Infinity Ward heads claiming that
Activision had manufactured a basis to
fire them Activision would then respond
with their own claim suing the to
developers for essentially trying to
steal Infinity Ward by the end of the
dispute 13 total members of Infinity
Ward left the company Infinity Ward
would maintain its name and continue
making Cod titles but never with those
same top developers that broke the mold
with modern warfare leaving the world
war 2 themed far in the past Infinity
Ward took a bold risk choosing a setting
much closer to our time this paid off
hugely with the game receiving rave
reviews and setting a new standard for
all first person shooters wanting to be
taken seriously card 4 introduced
modernized gun
attachments and explosives to the
franchise and was set in 2011 where
ultra-nationalists in Russia were trying
to restore the country to its Soviet era
form but it also brought about what may
be the most important feature to the
franchise's success an online
multiplayer mode it created an almost
permanent gaming experience never before
available to Call of Duty titles with
five player teams competing in a ranked
environment across multiple game modes
[Music]
[Music]
with Cod fours online experience your
game never ended you could conquer the
campaign reached the highest level
online and there was still a ladder to
climb even when every gun in your
arsenal was golden there was still
something to prove prestige enough gold
cross baby here's everybody in the room
all these lucky people are gonna be able
to see myself go prestige prestige
Christie's Steve's done gold cross baby
modern warfare was a game changer for
both the franchise and the gaming world
at large as it was the highest selling
game in the United States from 2007 to
2008 cod4 also allowed Call of Duty to
make the jump into eSports and it was
played for a full year on the MLG pro
circuit Hester was the last guy alive
for them yes their tournament hopes ride
with him and he's gone that's it and our
winners of the 2009 call duty for a
national champion and while Cod was
becoming everybody's favorite gaming
obsession it also took the internet by
storm
Hector hacks Rodriguez was the
Trailblazer that turned optic gaming
into the Call of Duty content creating
hub we know today
pick up the hex share bringing you my
top five favorite montages for college
reform of all time now I want to be very
clear about this these are my top five
favorite optic was largely built on the
foundation of never-ending play that
caught for offered this was a game that
people were in love with and because of
the breadth of the multiplayer options
available to its player
nobody wanted to stop playing so hex a
founding father of the Call of Duty
scene and the media that surrounded it
recruited players to help grow the optic
channel and the team's name for us the
way that that call of duty and sniping
was being developed and called before
she's you know spoke loudly of what we
were trying to do right I we started
because we - we started out as a
competitive plan and then when when
modern warfare one came out or called
the report came out I decided my brother
and I decide to turn optic into a sniper
all the clans hex knew exactly how
important content creation was going to
be in the gaming world and he was
willing to do anything it took to get
eyes on optic he bought a pirated copy
of call of duty modern warfare 2 in
order to be the first to release content
with the new game hexan optic tapped
into what enchanted fans about Call of
Duty so much the nasty plays
specifically when players had a sniper
rifle in their hands I'm gonna bill on a
one more
[Music]
optic we're attracting hundreds of
thousands of fans to their YouTube
channel to watch their players make
people look silly from 360 noscopes to
quick scopes and Snipes of incredible
distances optic was marketing they're
caught team in a way that's oddly
familiar to the highly marketed eSports
framework we have now it wasn't just
about being competitive optic was making
their franchise just as much of a TV
show as a competitive club it's a how
the [ __ ] you've done this in a shot and
today we're doing optic ribs with me so
there's something give me a little tour
now with that said optic were also the
best team in Call of Duty and no moments
showed that more than the first Call of
Duty XP in 2011 Call of Duty XP was a
cod convention as well as an eSports
event the XP eSports event was more or
less a release party for call of duty
modern warfare 3 and featured a
performance from Kanye West
to say that the first iteration of the
event in 2011 is a central piece of
calls history would be an understatement
quite simply the event was massive and
boasted the kind of hype stardom and
prize pool that we've come to expect
from modern eSports events as well as
excellence and also decidedly something
about it
[Applause]
we're taking over $400,000 there was no
debate that cod games were popular after
the first modern warfare almost tripled
call three sales gamers everywhere we're
talking about cod then black ops sold 30
million copies and modern warfare 2 sold
25 million the game was huge but the
competitive scene was scattered amongst
a number of third party events
throughout the year this made it pretty
difficult for the millions of Cod fans
to stay invested in the competitive
scene and its main characters that is
until the peak of the phase optic
rivalry optic gaming may have been the
Trailblazers for the eventual unity of
content creation and eSports that would
become so predominant in cod but they
fostered a whack of competitors on
YouTube looking to capitalize on that
same strategy and the greatest of those
competitors was faze clan
[Applause]
[Music]
the faze clan an optic gaming rivalry
was born on YouTube where both
organizations were fighting over the
same turf they waged wars over the
better snipe shot 360 noscope or trick
shot now of course that rivalry reared
its head on the eSports stage as well
after the release of Call of Duty
advanced warfare faze clan added Patrick
aches price and the pressure cooker that
was this rivalry spilled over how many
this event the world championships
caught up biggest event of the year
definitely something I want to get my
second ring in you know I'd have two
more than they chopped predictions for
this matchup map score up against face
red right now
we're gonna win three out whoa winning
it 308 back to you what are you gonna
think three versus three times
three he's gonna get the killed 29
seconds left bomb down phase versus
optic quickly became the most polarizing
and popular topic in caught esports and
this wasn't like modern-day esports
rivalries it was dirty there was trash
talk
[Music]
there was ingame BM after going up to Oh
optics gone up went back and now up
three 2x just stuff that shooting
buddies
teabagging nature obviously we saw them
in the pregame interview huge rivalry
between these two all absolutely and
once things got physical
[Music]
there is simply no story of Call of Duty
without the optic phase rivalry it
transcended multiple platforms and
allowed for the character-driven drama
that keeps fans hungry for more no
matter where caught ends up when it
comes to competitive play one thing is
for sure nobody will ever forget phase
versus off deck after optic seventh
place finish at the call of duty
championship in 2015
maybe the game's most recognizable face
made shot retired from playing cod
competitively I felt like in a sense I
was somewhat holding my team back there
I just need some time to step back and
really pursue other things and I'm
passionate about with made shots
retirement the most contentious era of
the optic phase rivalry had ended and so
did his personal on stage rivalry with
aches that said as optic vs. phase
started to fade the call of duty world
league was starting up as exciting as it
was to finally get a real eSports League
for cod world league started at a
difficult time
members of the Cod community had become
critical of the newer titles and the dev
team added jet packs and increased
mobility options that were much
different from the classic boots on the
ground caught experience the one thing
that everyone is the Scott
is whether they want exosuits or no
extra seats go back to classic call of
duty or stick with another game like
advanced warfare
this is weird now this were funeral I
think that the ending and parting words
would go a little something like this
called duty and family you were sort of
like that uncle that just nobody really
liked but we soared to just had to deal
with you you were forced upon us for how
long nine ten months now it's done your
time is up 2016 was a time where the
biggest names in eSports were really
starting to pick up steam Counter Strike
global Offensive had proven to be the
de-facto best FPS eSport and dota 2 and
League of Legends were both skyrocketing
in popularity
[Applause]
he undisputed best team in the world
[Applause]
Counter Strike still had its place on
YouTube but despite the excitement of
the World League cod just didn't blow up
on Twitch like these other games and it
didn't help that the game's most beloved
face had retired even the World League
wasn't able to compete with the likes of
Counter Strike there's no arguing the
impact that the cod era of eSports and
content creation had on the eSports
world that lies in front of us and now
like it or not we're in a world where
battle royale games feel like they pop
up every week and there might be no
better business model to apply to this
new format than Hex's content first
youtube strategy many of Cod's most
endemic organizations have jumped into
games like player unknowns battlegrounds
and fortnight and the enchantment you
felt on your parents old boxy computer
is being felt again by a new generation
of gamers learning to phase up in a new
game because of a history and a
groundwork laid by the heroes of Call of
Duty past in the past Cod has proven its
ability to succeed when taking a swing
at supplementary game modes back in 2008
they struck gold with the zombies game
mode in Call of Duty for that
the game-mode exploded and in the
mainstream was much more popular than
the rest of a game players just couldn't
get enough of killing hundreds of
zombies for hours on end while trapped
inside a broken-down house what's more
is that we now know those seems zombies
we've come to love will be present in
Cod's battle royale mode whether we like
it or not the battle royale era of these
sports is upon us and its latest edition
Call of Duty blackout has joined the
fray
midway through September of 2018 the
blackout PC open beta revealed itself to
a fortnight frenzied gaming world and
well blackout held its own he's got to
be down by the street either down by the
street behind the wall 120 there is I
see him let's go
potential collapse detection advise free
location to indicate it safe zone
discussing give no [ __ ] got a grab
the game hits you on two fronts on one
hand you've got everything you knew and
loved about your favorite Call of Duty
titles the maps the zombies the
grappling gun and even that annoying
little RC car while at the same time you
get the Battle Royale experience that
player unknowns battleground says
popularized and thrived off of that
whole jump off a plane and parachute
into a multi terrain wasteland and fight
for your life kind of thing and then do
it again and stream it and pop off it's
hard to believe but they seem to have
nailed both
[Music]
[Music]
this is probably gonna be so fun on PC
in four days holy [ __ ] dude I can't wait
I'm gonna grind it hard man I got a hold
on before I jump in this sex game
because I love this game I love it man I
love it love it Treyarch love it
the cod blackout era of twitch is upon
us
between the games release on October
12th and October 15th it had an average
of more than two hundred and fifty seven
thousand twitch viewers at a time at its
peak the game had almost four hundred
and fifty thousand viewers on day one of
the game's release shroud streamed it
for more than twenty four consecutive
hours
he alone averaged almost 60,000 viewers
and peaked at more than 87,000 hello oh
yes
the hype from Cod even drew attention
from the world's biggest fortnight's
streamers the likes of ninja Tim the tap
man Nick mercs
and more - team up their division has
even publicly stated that black ops 4
had the most day one digital sales in
Activision history combining the sales
from PC and console these impressive
statistics aside not all reviews have
exactly been glowing it needs a lot of
work it's still very early like it
doesn't feel perfect it doesn't feel
like perfect Battle Royale launched
they're still missing some key things my
opinion it's hard to argue that black
ops 4's release hasn't been a huge
success
but it takes a lot more than a few game
modes and some big names and numbers in
order to find longevity in the gaze of
twitches fickle purple eyes quite
frankly there is no touching the legacy
Call of Duty has made for itself this is
the quintessential shooter the game that
has conquered the living room couch the
eSports stage and now the front page of
twitch millions of players spanning the
entire globe learned how a killstreak
felt the swagger that pairs with a
landed headshot and how to team up to
secure an objective from one place it's
been over a year of this battle royale
blitz and there's a new contender
in the ring thanks for watching if you
want more great content just like this
be sure to hit the subscribe button
[Music]
you